it is a global race for a vaccine but
even those competing
worry it's going too fast baikon is a
japanese research institute with a
promising vaccine in the pre-trial stage
dr yoshiharu matsura heads the research
and he has serious concerns about the
rush for a remedy
[Music]
masura is worried that if a rushed
vaccine goes wrong the antibodies it
produces could end up making the
coronavirus stronger
instead of protecting against it it's a
phenomenon called
antibody dependent enhancement although
there's no evidence yet for it in covet
19.
but the pressures for a solution are
immense especially in japan
the delayed olympics are due to be held
in tokyo next summer
and they depend on a vaccine dr masura
says
and despite global commitment to share a
vaccine
practicalities mean countries will in
effect have to fend for themselves
it is a national effort one that extends
beyond vaccines to the other part of
dealing with coronavirus
effective medical treatment
cow is a cosmetics and cleaning company
it discovered antibodies from the alpaca
animal
could help treat covid19 although the
research is only in its very early
stages
japan has handled covert 19 pretty well
but cases are once again
on the rise and in the search for a
vaccine it is lagging behind
tom cheshire sky news